If we’re alive and more or less functioning,
if we’re capable of taking joy in things
occasionally, if we can be kind and grateful
to others, if we’re not addicted or very
drawn to killing ourselves, then it’s likely
that someone somewhere, early on, loved us
very much. They may live quite far away from
us now, they might share none of our interests
and could in many ways be a little boring
to spend time with – and yet we will continue
to be deeply loyal to them and know in our
hearts that we owe them everything. When we
say that someone ‘loved’ us, what we’re
really referring to is the acquisition of
a set of skills. These were not transferred
in any formal way, we imbibed them in the
ordinary bustle of daily life. It might have
been in the kitchen, on a walk out in the
woods or at night-time in the bedroom after
a story. It would have been easy to miss what
was really going on, the vital nectar that
was being imparted, all the life-sustaining
goodness we received when it looked like it
was just another conversation about homework
or the plans for the weekend. But in the course
of being loved, we got an encyclopedic emotional
education nevertheless, in which some of the
following was learnt: – Endurance Sometimes,
it all looked very bad indeed. We were in
a state, soaked in tears, or red with fury.
We felt the world was coming apart and that
we would not survive. But they kept the tragedy
at bay until we could breathe calmly once
again. They may not have had all the answers,
but they promised us – and they were right
– that a few would eventually emerge. They
held us through the night and guaranteed that
there would be a dawn. And ever since then,
it’s become just a little easier to keep
catastrophic dread at bay. – Self-Love They
lent us a sense that we were of value to them
and therefore could one day be to ourselves
as well. If we made something or had an idea,
we could share it with them – and though
it wasn’t perhaps entirely accomplished
already, they were guided by our underlying
intentions and promise. When we entered the
kitchen, not every time, but enough times
to form a protective layer over our ego, they
looked up and lit up. They might have had
a name for us: little champion, button chops
or sweet sheep. At one point in adolescence,
we certainly didn’t want that name used
any more, and it would be mortifying if colleagues
knew it today, but it remains a secret symbol
of an emotional bedrock upon which all our
later poise and confidence was able to emerge.
– Forgiveness At points, we did something
very wrong: we forgot a book, we scratched
a table, we were nasty to someone or exploded
in fury. The punishment could have been very
strong, and yet it wasn’t. They came up
with reasons that cast our misdeeds in a generous
light: we were tired, everyone does that,
no one is perfect. They taught us about mercy,
towards others and ourselves. They let us
know that we would not have to be perfect
to deserve to exist. – Patience We didn’t
master much immediately. It took us a while
to get long division, it was ages till we
found our way with the piano or learnt to
make biscuits. But they didn’t shout or
mock or get irritated. They taught us the
art of waiting till the good could emerge.
They didn’t demand immediate results – and
so spared us the need to panic or bluster
our way through life. – Repair There were
some very bad scenes. They said nasty things
and we did too. We felt we hated them a lot.
But they stuck around. They took the anger
– and thereby taught us about repair: how
things can go very wrong and yet can be fixed,
how resilient people can be, how many second
chances there are when love is involved. With
some of these lessons and more, we grew up
into people who could be kind to ourselves,
tolerant of our faults, sympathetic to others
and capable of keeping going. We weren’t
just ‘loved’, we got an education, whose
presence we can feel every time we can care
for someone else, address a kind word to ourselves
or feel strong enough to face a difficult
tomorrow.
We hope you enjoyed this film.  For more from The School Of Life you can subscribe to our channel and take a look at our range of products on our website.